IAN LAKE: A computer
file is a resource
for storing information.
Almost all the files
you're used to working with
are openable files-- files
with a direct representation
in bytes.
But there's actually
another kind of file--
a virtual file, a new part of
the Storage Access Framework
added in API 24.
Now, on Android,
a traditional file
is known as an openable file.
This comes from the fact that
you can open a file stream
and get directly at
the bytes that make up
the file via something
like openFileDescriptor
or openInputStream.
And in most cases when
you're using something
like getContent or
ActionOpenDocument,
this is exactly what you'd want.
So way back in API 1, Android
added CATEGORY_OPENABLE.
You'd add this to your
intent, and then you
could ensure that what you
got back could be opened.
Virtual files will appear,
but they won't be selectable.
If you're already
using that category,
never get a virtual
file, and you
don't need to worry about them.
But if you don't include
CATEGORY_OPENABLE,
the user will be able to
select both openable files
and virtual files.
In both cases, you'll be able
to get the document's metadata
and use other documents
provider APIs, such as getting
a thumbnail, if supported.
But beyond that, you'll need
to handle virtual files a bit
differently.
You can determine if you
have a virtual document
by using a method like this,
which looks at the column
flags for the URI.
That FLAG_VIRTUAL_DOCUMENT
is the indicator
which marks a virtual file.
With this information,
you can also
take advantage of one of
API 24's other new features,
alternate MIME types for the
Storage Access Framework.
Think of this as
on-the-fly transcoding
or exporting a virtual file into
an openable file, such as a PDF
file.
GetStreamTypes determines
what openable MIME types
are available--
say, checking if we
can get an image from the file.
Then use
openTypedAssetFileDescriptor
and createInputStream to get
an input stream for the file.
This is really
useful if you're just
wanting a one-time
export of a file,
say, to send as an
email attachment.
But for local viewing
and editing of the file,
you'll need to rely on the app
that provided the virtual file
in the first place.
In those cases, the virtual
file serves more just
as a link to a file, allowing
you to use ACTION_VIEW intent
to open the file in
the native app, which
would know how to
interact with whatever
crazy internal format or
database or cloud storage
system the document might
have under the hood.
So for developers interested
in using virtual files
in your documents
provider, you want
to make sure you add the
VIRTUAL_DOCUMENT flag
to each virtual document.
Then make sure you
have an activity that
supports ACTION_VIEW
for the MIME types you
use on those virtual documents.
That way, there's at least one
app that can render the file.
And if you want to provide
an alternate MIME type that
is openable, which is
strongly recommended,
override getDocumentStreamTypes
and openTypedDocument.
Just make sure to call
the super implementations
for non-virtual files.
This ensures that every
client app can call it,
whether explicitly checking
whether it's a virtual file
or not.
So make sure that
you're explicitly
including
CATEGORY_OPENABLE if you
want to ensure openable files,
and handling virtual files
correctly in every other case.
Check out the links in the
description for all the details
as you continue to
build better apps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]